so bitcoin is currently by far the most
uh popular sort of dominant
cryptocurrency that said
and i look forward to your letters
bitcoin maximalists
uh that said you know internet explorer
was the most popular
browser yeah for quite a long time and
then
other browsers came along that out
competed it like chrome
firefox
people should check out brave it's a
great browser um i think it's my
favorite browser at this point anyway so
why bitcoin why not another
cryptocurrency if you look in the next
10 20 50 100 years do you think it's
possible for another cryptocurrency like
ethereum or something that it's not even
here yet
to overtake bitcoin as a mechanism
when you say overtake
um
what do you mean what do you mean
overtake you mean number of users do you
mean a price per coin then yeah the
number of users because we're talking
about one percent two percent yeah and
if we are serious about this being um
in the space of money as a way to
give
individuals power
yeah fight the centralized powers that
are used the money system and so on
how do we get from two percent to 50
right to 60
to 80 percent
that that jump is it obvious to you not
obvious but
do you think
bitcoin is the way to get from two
percent to 50
or are there going to be other
cryptocurrencies they may emerge that
get us to 50 no i mean bitcoin is the
innovation the innovation is in having
the decentralized mint no one can change
the monetary policy everything else is
downstream from there in bitcoin the
mean would be 21 million there's never
going to be any more than 21 million
every other cryptocurrency either has an
inflationary policy i mean there's going
to continue to be more and more of it
over time or its monetary policy can be
changed by a small group of people this
is vividly on display in ethereum which
is like the second largest and second
most robust cryptocurrency right i've
talked to senior ethereum engineers
over the last couple weeks trying to
figure out
what is the monetary policy of ethereum
no one can tell me no one knows how much
eath is going to be minted in 2022 and
2023 after they shift to proof of stake
it i've seen estimates that range from
100 000 to 2 million so at the end of
the day you're going to be trusting a
small group of people to make those
decisions that is what we are escaping
with bitcoin so all these other
cryptocurrencies they might have their
use cases virtually all of them are not
it's very important for people to know
that if you take like the 4 500
cryptocurrencies on coin market cap
almost all of them are scams straight up
even the ones that have like noble
intentions
i just don't think you're gonna add that
much value um ultimately i think bitcoin
to me is the innovation and and you know
that's because it has a monetary policy
and an issuance schedule that cannot be
changed and that's what gets me so
excited about i mean that's why it's
such an important tool for human rights
yeah it's it's interesting because when
you grow from two percent when you grow
in
the number of people using it at the
scale they're using it
it
it's going to need to be resistant to
governments and institutions messing
with it
so it's interesting to see what kind of
um what kind of cryptocurrency would be
resistant to that obviously dogecoin is
going to win let's be honest
well i mean looking forward to the
number two cryptocurrency in the world
probably by like how useful it is to
people is tether which is totally
centralized has blacklists so i'm not
saying there won't be like new digital
assets that are lumped into this
category that have usage but they're not
they're not it's not the same innovation
as bitcoin it's just sort of building on
this idea of like a euro dollar maybe
like a dollar that is minted outside of
the control of the u.s federal reserve
right it would be a euro dollar so
stable coins are kind of like euro
dollars just minted by private actors in
a way right but they're still tied to
the dollar they're pegged to the dollar
they're not escaping the system escaping
the system is bitcoin we we aren't
reliant on the dollar we we have our own
you know full um store value medium of
exchange unit of account eventually and
you know the bitcoin world will be
denominated in different terms and i
think everyone everything else will be
tied to it i really do
you